our next speaker is judith lichtman
who is susan dwight bliss professor and
chair of chronic disease epidemiology at
yale school of public health and
director of the humanities arts and
public health practice at yale or happy
initiative
dr litman's research focuses on
examining the epidemiology of stroke and
heart disease using longitudinal
databases and prospective observational
studies she has served on several
national committees related to
cardiovascular and cerebrovascular
disorders and has been a member of the
program committee for the american heart
association conference on cardiovascular
disease epidemiology and prevention and
has served on numerous national american
heart association and american stroke
association writing committees she was
the recipient of the c miller fischer md
neuroscience visionary award from the
aha and the aasa in 2018 and is a
graduate of the drexel university
executive leadership in academic
medicine program
dr lichtman has been the principal
investigator for projects funded by the
goddess foundation the fannie e ripple
foundation the american heart
association the centers for disease
control and prevention national
institute on aging the agency for
healthcare research and quality the
national heart lung and blood institute
and the national institute of
neurological disorders and stroke
all right well thank you so i have to
say i mean it's wonderful to to revisit
some of those accomplishments but i want
to say i'm a graduate
of the of the program here and so um i
have to say my area was in epidemiology
i have been living the past little while
across the bridge over in the school of
public health and around the medical
center and what's really fun about
coming today and hearing that incredible
project is that
i've always had roots in music and dance
and and art and i sort of feel like i'm
enjoying a treasure hunt across campus
finding out about and really trying to
build something that that goes beyond
sort of my area but to really extend
across the different arts and
disciplines so what i want to do today
is talk a little bit about the vision of
what it is i'm trying to build and we're
in process
share with you a course and a new course
that's coming out this spring that we're
really excited about and then just tell
you about one or two projects and again
i'm very interested in hearing about
potential collaborations or
opportunities because it's really
exciting to see where you are in your
your own career development and i have
to say yale is an amazing space um as i
said i've been here a little while and
i'm still exploring new new territory so
it's a lot of fun
so what we really want to do with the
happy initiative is is develop an
interdisciplinary program that really
builds on health the arts and humanities
looking at all of the rich resources
across yale
we're basing it in the school of public
health that's my hub and we really are
giving it more of a public health
perspective how to enhance the health of
communities through
understanding important public health
issues but how can we translate and
communicate it through the arts
and so
one of the things we have sort of a
three-pronged approach we want to have
collaboration which is what's exciting
here to sort of see what everybody's
doing to really build collaborations to
eventually establish a center that
focuses on this with
certainly invited scholars having guest
artists and really having a good hub for
these kinds of conversations we also
want to have education to really train
everybody to use insert
interdisciplinary arts to promote
community health
and we are working on a track within my
school but also thinking across campus
and then research
that's as you heard a bit of my hub is
to really conduct research that
evaluates and comes up with how to
measure outcomes of art-based
programming so how can we improve
community health and prove that a lot of
this exposure is really going to improve
an individual's health and and and the
overall health of their community
so one of the things and i'm sure many
of you are from different areas here
part of what is really fun and as i said
the treasure hunt is to sort of build
collaborations and we've been doing that
very effectively so far we've been
working with individuals i should change
it now from school of drama to the the
geffen school so it's a little bit older
sorry but what is interesting is you
know again how many schools are under
our umbrella but also we think about all
of the other art galleries museums
libraries everything else that are just
so rich to yale to be thinking about how
can we incorporate programs and
conversations that really bridge across
these disciplines
one of the collaborations that we're
really excited about is we've been
working with garth ross and jennifer
newman thinking about
using
and working with the schwarzman center
for me as i said sort of being over in
the more medical campus it really is a
wonderful environment i'm sure many of
you have already been there you've seen
the beautiful new resources
but it's amazing that the dance space
the the um
all the different areas and technologies
that we're hoping to take advantage of
to really immerse ourselves in thematic
work and also display so many of the
different arts that are available
and it really provides a unique lens
into public health and the arts by being
able to have conversations that that
bridge and i'll talk about one or two of
those
tyga christie who was a graduate of our
mph program in the social behavioral
sciences is what this can is an
inaugural schwarzman fellow what that
means is it's really exciting for us i
mean she knows the disciplines of our
work um but she also is really having
important conversations and
introductions for us within the
schwarzman center to be able to think
about developing
programs
and events that really are dedicated to
this intersection and can also
introduce individuals across campus
um the
uh we feel that we're also helpful to
the schwarzman center's mission of
building a sense of belonging by
providing some of these unique uh
opportunities to discover and connect
and one of the themes that we're working
on right now is a theme of sleep we all
need sleep it's one of what we call sort
of the the three pillars of a stool you
know you need to eat you need to
exercise you also need to sleep
and what's fun about this is we've been
starting to have conversations where
we've been bringing together the experts
in sleep who can talk about what you do
when you sleep uh brain cleansing
circadian rhythms all the things that
are really important for your health
we're also talking with for example
individuals from the guffin school of
drama where we're talking about safety
issues shift work how does that work
we're also talking with individuals
about equity of sleep who who has good
sleeping environments we're working with
professors and individuals from the
school of architecture what is the ideal
sleeping environment so we are starting
to think about not only the the broad
range of importance of sleep and how
well it's connected we're thinking about
um plays and music all that have
showcased the importance of sleep and
the detrimental issues related to not
having adequate sleep and of course for
all of us whether it be uh graduate
student level or faculty level we know
there there are important times when we
are not getting enough sleep and we have
to think about how that impacts health
so
stay tuned we're planning quite a few
events that we will be bringing across
campus to really think about that and
showcase it
i'm also really excited when we think
about
this kind of approach we have a
incredible collaborator that i was
fortunate to be introduced to about a
year and a half ago dr neil bear he's a
physician author and award-winning
showrunner and television writer
producer
he is very passionate about public
health being an advocate and he really
uses media to tell impactful stories and
so he works from the approach that you
need to have it based in science and
evidence but then you really have to
trigger an emotional response to things
it's not just about the numbers but how
do you really
uh invoke the emotional response to
really want to drive change and end
policy so again i i would uh
his list is very long but again i think
for us it's really exciting to be
working with someone who is very
visionary and really wants to connect
all of the dots and think about
effective storytelling because that for
us is a public health discipline and
through many of the other arts is really
important and compelling
i also want to mention karen deary who's
here who's really the hub of making sure
we connect with everybody across campus
so let me just so that's collaboration
education we really are trying to think
about multi-disciplinary courses that
take advantage of understanding public
health issues
from the perspective of the science as
well as how they might be displayed to
have been historically and how they
might be used to really raise awareness
and
invoke change so i want to talk about my
inaugural happy course in just a minute
but that's the as i said collaboration
education
um and then research we really want to
build build an evidence base for ethical
practical use of arts and humanities to
improve health outcomes it seems obvious
but there really is an important gap in
the field and what's really exciting
from my perspective is that
organizations like the national
institutes of health are really
recognizing this importance and there
are now requests for funding
announcements for example i'm working
with um dean robert blocker from the
school of music there are new rfas
request funding announcements that are
very much related to
brain health music all aspects of
recovery as mentioned i'm very
interested in stroke so stroke recovery
is something that's very interesting to
me to understand how music and dance are
very very helpful in recovery
and then part of what's important and
i've heard this from
garth from schwarzman center who spent a
lot of time
down at the kennedy center for arts is
we also need to be thinking about how do
you evaluate the impact and there really
is a lot of work methodologically to do
so let me just take a couple minutes and
talk about the course that we're
planning so this is a picture of the
historical library over at the medical
school which is going to be very much
involved in our course we really want to
challenge our students to explore the
possibilities problems and potential
uses of arts and humanities in public
health
so we're planning field trips all around
the campus we've already talked with
one of the art historians we're going to
pull out a lot of materials
that have been historically
provided whether it be
how things have been recorded how things
have been relayed in
advertisements so that we really are
building conversations around
particular themes
we want to really look at expertise
across campus i'm going to show you
pictures of other places we're going to
go on our field trip and we really want
to think about methodologies not only
study design and things like that but
how do we really
think about the impact of some of these
things on our own perceptions and how
will we utilize these to think about
community health
here we expect to be going to the
libraries i mean the museums uh to
really take a look at how some public
health themes have been relayed in art
um and so the format which is very
different for me is uh we're gonna have
sort of two sessions a week one will be
more lecture-oriented content area the
other one's going to be very hands-on
it's going to be going to as i said some
of the libraries some of the museums we
have some concerts picked out some
performances so that we're really trying
to reflect on how these two are both
integrated and sometimes not integrated
we're going to really focus on ethics
and problems since art and health work
storytelling social cohesion and medical
humanities and social science to kind of
build this methodologic base and then
we're really going to be thinking about
what are some of the important public
health themes that we want to get across
so some of them for example might be
things like climate change disaster and
humanitarian aid opioids and harm
reduction violence and gun violence
sleep and health disparities
mental health hiv aids the built
environment and health disparities
health impact of incarceration which was
wonderful to hear and um we'll be
working with one of my former students
byron kennedy i don't know if you've met
him uh
who who's very involved in in the
medical system for the prison systems in
connecticut and then neuroscience and
the arts and i just want to mention that
part of this also is to look at plays
this is actually a scene from a play
that was written directed and produced
by as i mentioned tyga christie who is
our fellow and it was an important piece
in that it really looked at the stress
of front-line workers ems workers she
did qualitative work to understand the
issues she developed a play and then it
was shown to
ems workers and their families and it
led to very important discussions about
many of those issues
the assessments that we're going to do
which is a little different is weekly
reading reflections so we really want
people to think about their response to
a lot of these issues so that
we really want people to come up with
where these things connect in their own
lives we want individuals
to create a manifesto sort of a value
assignment that's a kind of a living
document
that will grow with the work that they
do and then we really want a final
project which is to create an arts or
humanities inspired intervention on a
specific health topic
i'm also showcasing here we talked about
music this is one of our former students
who also
had a wonderful series of recitals
during her time here
so that's the course a couple things
that we have put together just to give
you an idea is we
hosted uh dr neil bair
had been the executive producer for a
documentary welcome to chechnya
which was
a powerful david france documentary
about anti-gay purges in the late 2010s
for lgbt refugees
they were wearing hidden cameras made
their way out of russia through a
network of safe houses and it was really
amazing it was nominated it was on the
short list i should say for
an oscar it won a special jury at
sundance um what was interesting about
it is that we put together a panel which
was neil bear we also had our dean john
pachankas who's in
really his area is an lbgtq health
leosha gorshov who's also in academics
but has been a
refugee and also a
a lawyer deirdre stradone who is an
expert in getting people asylum so it
was really we provided the
documentary we gave people time to look
at it and then we really put together a
panel that we thought could get at some
of the the issues the social political
issues that we thought would be really
important um
we also and it was wonderful to see the
readings that and the letters that you
were describing um we put together a
pandemic archive and it's been very
interesting we we
opened it up to the yale community and
beyond and got wonderful contributions
about people's responses uh and
impressions and thoughts about what
their lives were like during that time
which we think as as you were hearing is
a really important expression um and and
uh way for many people to think about um
getting through what was such a
difficult time
and then
some other things we've done
we
provided opportunity for uh we invited a
group of students and staff across uh
the whole campus to view a play do no
harm
that was really around the stories of
three enslaved black women
and the medical experimentation that
they
endured and suffered through
and following the screening we had a
conversation with the playwright
and the play commissioner and really had
a very
wonderful dialogue about many of the
issues that were involved
and then finally we have a couple things
in process i mentioned
tiger christie's work counting pebbles
but we also
are currently working and she's leading
the initiative on an original play about
climate change communication in the
context of covid we got funding from a
outside foundation for that and we're
also going to be hosting a touring
performance of ezell
in the spring so let me stop there um
and just say please if their interests
contact me i would love to we're very
much at the early stages of developing
something and
all ideas and energy is welcome
[Applause]
i'll start um so obviously
the research itself will have an impact
on the community are there ways in which
you're thinking about involving the
community and some of this work oh
absolutely um i think for us there uh by
having some of the plays go out in the
community is certainly one of those
aspects but yes we're thinking about
some of the collaborations and some of
the projects that we want to do very
much we feel that we want to engage
individuals in the community so that it
feels like not only is it nested here
it's nested in new haven we have been
thinking also about any kinds of
work that we could
think about so one of the things we've
been thinking about is sort of a tool
kit where we go out into the community
on thematic issues and really talk with
individuals get their impressions what
are some of the challenges around this
issue so we would definitely go out to
thought leaders
individuals who are in environment
situations much like i think you know
yours was a perfect example and part of
what we've been talking about is trying
to prepare a toolkit that you put
together some of the key messaging and
we want to be able to then share that
with with artists with individuals
certainly but we are thinking about
packaging we've been talking about
working with singer songwriters in
nashville
thinking about meals connected with the
hollywood guild making sure that some of
these snippets and experiences are
really going to outlets where they would
be shared
as well as providing potentially
vignettes and stories about health that
could go out to the community and be
used for sparking and igniting
conversation about health issues so yes
we very much feel like uh working in
close collaboration with individuals
outside of of the yale community to
really understand
many aspects and dimensions of public
health issues is really critical thank
you
hi thank you so much for that
presentation um i'm i'm on the staff at
dwight hall yale which is the center for
public service and social justice on
campus and in our experience we've
worked with so many community partners
with grassroots arts initiatives and
other things as well as performers and
artists individuals collectives etc and
one of the challenges locally and i
suspect and i know nationally as well is
that oftentimes arts organizations and
grassroots artists struggle
to obtain funding for a lot of their art
and they often feel the pressure to
associate art
with something else so it's art and
youth development art and health art and
economic development for instance so how
how do you anticipate um
do you anticipate that
your findings and your research will
provide some tools for organizations to
be able to seek more stable and
sustainable support for you and
conversely how you anticipate
uh the challenge of this exacerbating
that heart and
kind of challenge
um and then finally as part of that um
how how do you consider kind of the
cultural equity
and the challenge of whose art gets
promoted
sure no those are great questions and i
think those are very much uh issues that
that we are processing i feel very
fortunate that tiger christie who is an
integral member of our team
raises our awareness very much about
these issues
we we are bringing artists into the
class and making sure that all artists
are compensated appropriately so that we
we also realize often in art it's it's
almost as if it's supposed to be a
volunteer activity or something which we
we are very cognizant it's uh i as
someone who's married to a violinist i
very much appreciate uh the the sphere
of the artist i think your your question
about dissemination and sharing and also
sustainability are very much issues that
we're we're thinking about
i think as i mentioned in response the
idea of the toolkit is to
make some of these um
insights and thoughts and impressions
from individuals and and perspectives
around public health issues available to
artists so the idea is that
we would like to provide information
that could help them build their art
support their art
i think ultimately for us as a center i
very much want to think about
opportunities and resources to support
development of art and sustainability of
art i mean i think we would like to have
artists in residence but also ultimately
i would very much like to have resources
that could go out to artists for pilot
programs
exhibits so i think that
for us a goal would be to provide
resources as well
i think what is exciting from my
perspective as someone who's been in in
the research field i am seeing more and
more recognition of the importance of
art
in wellness there is an epidemiologist
daisy fan court who's in the uk who has
really been looking at large data sets
and demonstrating that exposure to art
and engagement
can be associated with preventive issues
for for health uh longevity um better
mental health uh there are also positive
um
associations for children so i think um
you know in the bigger picture i think
it would be to continue to find
resources to support those things and
then think about interventions and
programs that would then
enable artists to be part of this sort
of community health
does that help answer the question great
thank you yeah
uh thank you so much
wonderful
um so i have a question
for the last one
if you could talk a little bit about if
this initiative would also have some
policy impact on yale's theory because
as a
employee uh employer because uh they
hired a lot of partners but also as you
said
they hired all sorts of people including
black students but people who work in
the services
and emergency services
and i'm wondering if some of the
findings that you are
finding out and discovering are
that the question is is a bit of um
bringing some of this work more to the
yale administration and staff is that
yeah so um it's a great question i think
we're still at some early stages where
we where we are working on sort of the
education the collaborations i mean i i
would anticipate that the programs we
put forward are to be to the whole yale
community so for example the events that
we're thinking about um for example a um
a health fair on sleep would be open to
everybody um how that might impact
policy as far as
staff employees i think we're not i
don't think we're there at this time but
i appreciate the perspective that it
again if if these are effective
opportunities interventions exposures we
would like to
initially here you know make them
available to the entire yale community
as we discover things and as more comes
out about the evidence i would hope that
it would certainly be something that we
would bring forward to inform you know
overall community health here within
yale as well thank
thank you thank you so much
[Music]
you